so okay so welcome everyone to uh the
first P data in h one so P zest this the
first time in h one so welcome everyone
um and some of you know already the
procedure some of you might not um so
this a disclaimer we recording the
Meetup I we streaming live on the pi
data Channel on YouTube or LinkedIn on
Twitter also we recording also like
audience questions so yeah so you have
been
informed um yes so this is the 28th
pataa zwest pataa zwest started uh as a
collaborative meet up from yeah actually
after the Cal conference we said okay
pataa now is with the Berlin Conference
let's do something local and so we had
Caro idle at Manheim and now we're
really happy to include hyron as well so
and um so welcome everybody here uh at
home and at the screens and this brings
us to the people watching online and the
stream uh so hbr what is hbr hbr is in
Southwest Germany as you might guess
from the Meetup name and some of you
already know this slide where tell hey
where are we located in Germany and I
let me show you like the the
distribution of universities and the
best universities in Germany and you see
there's um it's not everything is in
Berlin because if I'm I'm inational
conferences people always ask me oh
you're from Germany you're from Berlin
no I'm not from Berlin so I'm from
Southwest and we are here in highw one
which has also a university and it's
actually a collaboration with the um
university of Munich that's why there's
this little uh line there um also this
is the distribution of companies the
most most important German companies you
see we have like um yeah this is the
distribution speaks for itself so no the
economic power is not in Berlin we see
we have all yes yeah some people don't
know that especially International so we
see we have all the German um Excellence
um companies down here in the South many
people many companies you know like
Bosch or like porer and and so on and so
on um and yeah we're just like basically
in the middle of it in hardland of the
German industry and this brings us to
our host eai and would like oh
sorry oh no I think uh no sorry sorry
that's that's I added that slide but you
will be there Min uh let let's go to
that so um I think it's very important
this is a very inclusive and open
community so please raise your hands if
you were here around at the first time
at the Pata Meetup wow very warm welcome
to you
welcome to P datas Z West
um
and so everybody's a name tag yeah Nikki
took care of that um it's very important
this is an open Community there are no
stupid questions just interact with
people talk there's no stupid questions
at all like the best tricks I learned
from chatting with people at pataa
meetups in the breaks um and we have
this Pacman rule so what's the Pacman
rule the Pacman rule is people stand in
circles
and always leave a spot open so somebody
else can just join in and also please
invite them hey join the conversation
let's talk and then you meet new people
and learn new
things so pataa zest um as I already
mentioned pataa is uh was initiated by n
Focus num focus is a us-based foundation
which supports many um scientific
packages uh you probably might use a few
of them or many of them in your daily
work or research um uh so um no focus is
all about um scientific Computing and
supporting open source um we have a code
of conduct uh so as I told you like we
don't we do not tolerate any harassment
in the of community in any way uh if you
have questions there's the non Focus
code of contact online if
you feel uh if you think there's
something you want to report or if you
think something inappropriate happen
just talk to the organizers like me or
Kevin on video Ops here behind the
scenes
yeah and or you can also like report
this online so it's very important
everybody feels welcome and we
yeah so uh this is the Meetup we are
just like hi here in the middle um in
pataa zwest uh we also have a YouTube
channel we're streaming to the pataa
YouTube channel um it's very important
for us to record conference talks also
if possible the meetups and share the
knowledge on on um on YouTube and this
is not just like hey YouTube's cool so
actually I was sitting in the train to
berin to the pon the in P data
conference and I was chatting with a
colleague and we mentioned some stuff
and there was sitting somebody else just
across of us and said oh yeah why are
you talking about this and I said yeah
and he said yeah I'm from Nigeria I
watched your videos and I learn from
them and so this is really working it's
not a theory it was really like yeah the
best proof ever um so um hi West is
already 5 years old crazy isn't it we
are almost 1,00 members now um so um
ping us if you want to give a talk um we
always look for speakers um today we
don't have lightning talks because we
have three talks uh but if you want to
contribute a talk or lightning talk
there's a link you can also check the QR
code or it's also on the Meetup site and
of course if you also work for a company
and want to host the meet just ping us
because we're also look always looking
for
hosts and this brings us to today's
sponsors um we have uh applied AI uh
providing us the food and drinks with
have the Epi for providing the venue and
Kix week for um supporting the
organization oh no food today that was
sorry that copy paste that was from the
Big Data barbecue sorry for that so um
so please welcome ahed from EPI and he
will tell you a bit more about eepi
thank you you
go so hello and welcome we are happy to
host you for the first event in hbr in
Epi space and I will give you a little
introduction about what's EPI and what
we are doing so first I'm Ahmed I'm part
of Epi I work in the corporate real
estate uh Department I am responsible
for the building information modeling
and all the topics related to
digitalization especially digital twin I
know digital twin is kind of buzz word
nowadays but yeah because we are
developing a digital twin for the main
campus so who are we we are trying our
vision to be the global home of human AI
That's EPI and we are developing eepi
gradually so we are now in the first
phase of Epi which is this building so
that's the phases uh step one or first
phase that's this location with 1,200 M
Square next phase I'm not sure if you
saw it but it's just the building across
here next to this building it's called
velf so that's the second phase which
will have 6,000 square meters and it
will be open in 6 months this year and
then the main vision and the big vision
is the eepi compass which is the first
phase of it which is the part in the
middle should be open in
2027 so here uh we are are building the
initial ecosystem with the first
strategic partner and that's part of the
our uh members and partners
here and second phase velf that's the
design of it and yeah that's all the
amenities for it like the spaces so it
will have real lab uh also an app space
which is very important for everyone
there and yeah we are also it's for us
also the test phase for the main campus
so we are trying a lot of new ideas
related to digitalization and also for
uh the office uh in inside offices
inside
also and then the third phase which is a
big uh AI campus and uh with the help of
all our partners members we are also uh
being with the uh stateof art
Technologies we are trying to make it
like a home of AI in all
Europe so thank you and I'm happy to
have you here and also to be a
participant in the meeting with you and
thank
[Applause]
you I'm leaving this yeah no problem
so yeah thanks also from my side for
hosting uh it's really great it's also
like we have plaman today no pizza and
now I would like to introduce it to Lan
Yan Willam from a FL
[Applause]
AI
see if I can clip this on somewhere hi
all welcome you all and it's very nice
to see you um with P data here uh here
in hon my name is Klein I'm the head of
ml engineering at apply and I will say a
few words about basically who we are and
um and what we're doing so PDI is a
nonprofit organization we have slightly
more than 30 people and our goal is to
create and share knowledge on how you
can apply the latest AI technologies
that are around there and specifically
we're focusing on doing this in a
reliable and in a trustworthy manner so
what does this mean this means that for
instance we create insights on the AI
act and see what can this do for you as
a professional and how can you apply
thei in a in trustworthy fashion we also
develop open source software to make it
easier for you to do this we have
training programs and courses this is
for students or for uh for young
professionals and companies around
really to do basically upscaling um of
uh of AI we um have sort of AI
Innovation insights showing what is
happening in the startup landscape um
Etc and we organize events on bringing
people in the ecosystem and in the
community together we organize seminars
we organize U events and and meetups and
also Yeah by sponsoring events like um
like
today now if you are interested sort of
in what AI is doing and say hey I would
like to also attend one of those events
you can uh find more information on
basically any uh social media platform
of uh of your choice and I just want to
wish you a lot of fun today learn a lot
meet a lot of uh a lot of new people and
just have a good
time yeah thank you very much
yeah so that brings us to Z from Kix
week here you go thank you thank you
very much hi I'm sir um I'm CEO of kwick
and together with Alex I'm here and
super happy finally to be here in Halon
because uh I personally uh family
background is not only in heidleberg
where I located but also in Bavaria so
I'm many many years I now go back and
forth on the A6 and I always thought
like well okay what about Halon and now
finally we are here and I think it's the
thrill thing after 5 years that we
together founded P zest so coming from
Que phix week we are a data n AI um
consultancy company as you can see here
we are super passionate about uh
everything in this field and that's why
we uh in addition to that also support
from the uh very logic of our internal
DNA anything around open source and
that's why we contribute into Pata with
West but also into uh Pyon um and
anything about Community um so whenever
and wherever you might be interested in
any kind of collaboration with please uh
get to our homepage get in interaction
with us uh discuss with us and meet us
in person during the breaks have a nice
drink together um I will now not talk
too much about what we do in concrete
projects or whatever why I'm super glad
and happy that Simon of our team is
today here and he will give us a little
bit Enlightenment of what's going on on
a day-to-day operational basis
nevertheless I wish you all a very very
fun evening today here and looking
forward to commuting it and chat with
you later thank you very
much thank you to
you so we also have a LinkedIn group um
this is moderated so no recruiters no
spam um it's just for us so please join
um this is the agenda we hear the
welcome we will soon start with the
first talk uh we have two talks in a row
and uh then we have a break and the
break is in the third floor and the good
thing is we don't have pizza to today we
have oh what is it FL yeah which is FL
out in English which is more like French
actually to me um yeah so uh yeah
um without further Ado we come to
community announcements now
so who knows this
building you know oh yeah only two oh
three four yeah okay this is uh this is
the inside of the building and here you
are see on stage an a colleague from uh
from y Yan villm is Paula um she also
unfortunately she's sick so get well
soon Paula if you're watching um we're
here on stage it's a Community Driven
conference at the BCC in bin and good
news ah it's coming back in April and uh
actually we had a record submissions of
proposals almost 500 which only says
like only 20% will be or are accepted
so um the program will be released very
soon um tickets sell fast so better get
your ticket um now than never and we
have a call for volunteers on site open
which is can be found under this link or
you can just like go there and subscribe
to our newsletter to be informed about
updates and this year we also have a
really great celebration it's actually
10 years of Pi data bin which is pretty
cool we're doing this for 10 years now
um there's also pady suit vest locally
um there's going to be um a meetup on
March 6th for the international women's
day um just go Um on Meetup and look for
pades at West joins it's um pades is um
enabling women in Tech
and we also I mentioned we always have a
open call for speakers for meetup so
share your experience with the community
five minute lightning talk a full talk
yeah um the Meetup is safe space you can
uh train for a big conference talk or
submission later and uh organizers are
be also happy to mentor and help you um
with the talk and I think that brings us
to my colleague Simon which will talk
about how to transform your business a
road map to being data driven with data
Ops and we know
switching it's all going to be F and yes
all companies with clean
data so
yeah
oh thank you very
much and indeed it worked
nice so also welcome from my side I'm
the last part in the trio of K who is
here today and I'm going to speak about
a road map to being data driven with
data operations
today and I will do so in three steps
we're g to start with something
introductory what is data Ops why is
data Ops really cool why do you want to
have data Ops then we're going to have a
look at the second part how to get
started how to identify potential in
your company and then we're going to
spend half of the talk on something
practical where we're going to have a
look at two use cases so you only need
to make it through the first 10 minutes
and then we'll have something
practical so without further Ado and
then dragging out the theory stuff data
operations
101 and for this talk I wanted to do
everything very nice and clean and I
googled around what's the textbook
definition of data
operations and as typical in AI it seems
that there are 100 definitions if you
ask 50 people so I think it's most
instru Ive actually if you think about
data operations as the data machine room
of your company you can think of this
analog to let's say a large cruise ship
you have a machine room that provides
power and propulsion to you but you
don't want to have to run down there if
you're the captain off the boat and get
your hands all dirty every time you need
to change course so you want to have a
machine room that takes care of all the
technical stuff and therefore the goal
of data Ops is have a dedicated unit
ensuring quality and availability of
your data you want to enable people to
work with data without bothering them
too much with all of the data management
hassles and to stay in the analogy with
the cruise ship not every cruise ship is
the same depending on if you're cruising
in the Antarctic or if you're cruising
in the tropics if you have 100 or 6,000
passages on board data operations as
well needs to be tailed to your specific
needs I've given you the two current
hype examples a data mesh and data Fab
and very abstract
here um with this out of the way why is
data Ops really great it's great not
only because it improves the
availability and reliability of the data
for the Departments working with the
data in your
organization but also because if you
implement data Ops using open source
software you can establish a vendor
independent way to deal with your data
so you're saving potentially a lot of
money um by avoiding licensing fees if
you're going open source and you can
avoid vendor lock in which can be really
handy in the long run um you can work at
your own pace prioritize what you need
exactly when you need it and you decide
which data goes where which I guess will
be the talk the theme of the third
talk um so you might be wondering now do
I need data Ops and here I brought you
something that we're using internally on
the bottom left side you can see how we
as kisg are categorizing different
companies and it ranges from data naive
to being highly AI optimized depending
on the level of technological
Improvement in your organization and the
level of how important data is to your
core business processes and I've brought
you the six core things here for being a
data driven company and you can see
you're relying heavily on Data Insights
for decision making and data analysis
and AI are becoming Central to Core
Business processes so you got to make
sure sure that these things
work and that's where data operations is
Handy um the only problem with all of
this
is this is how we come up with the
assessment the whole thing is not
exactly straightforward and that's why
we're going to have a look at how to get
started in your specific case in the
second part of this
talk uh which I labeled your data
treasure map because in order to get
started with data operations you need to
identify two different set of things the
first thing you need to identify is the
treasure itself how much data do you
have is your data AI relevant what types
of data is prevalent in your
organization how many data points do you
have have you a history with your data
like is it historized all of these
things and you might be saying now of
course I know easy no problem and I
would contend that if you're working in
an organization ation which is just now
moving into being data driven and is in
business for more than five years
probably you don't know that's the funny
thing um usually there is not only
significant heterogenity across
departments in data quality and quantity
so if I ask you working in Department x
what does Department y have actually in
terms of data you might be surprised but
also there tend to be a lot of CEOs and
what I labeled knowledge hoarders these
tend to be very dedicated people taking
care of their silos guarding it
enviously and as soon as they retire you
realize that they were the only person
capable of handling the data in this
department specifically which brings us
neatly to the second thing you need to
know which I labeled your data Black
Market that's another thing that's just
bound to happen if you don't have good
data operations in your company and you
have been in business for a while you
know things just
happen put yourself in the shoes of
somebody who needs to make a report
you're asking your colleague from sales
hey can you give me the newest sales
data he or she sends over an Excel file
you're making the report somebody else
in sales didn't add their recent sales
to the list you go into the meeting the
report is already outdated two days
after it's been made nobody can trace
the error nobody knows what's going on
so you see these unregulated d uh data
flow are badly traceable super error
prone produce silos redundancies and
breaks super easy if you colleague from
Mark from sales goes on holidays do you
just stop making reports or do you ask
somebody else who's then digging into a
colleagues emails it's it's all messy
but at the same time these undocumented
data flows tell you something very
important they tell you how data in your
organization would need to flow an ideal
scenario they show you a need
so now you might be wondering that's all
nice and well but how do I figure this
out and the unfortunate truth of it is
shoe leather there is no easy way to
getting all of this stuff sorted out
beside talking to people which can be
quite uncomfortable at times that's the
second point on the slide you need a
neutral view to get an idea who is
guarding which
Silo and depending on how um what's the
polite way to put this depending on how
passionate they guarding their Silo this
can become quite
unpleasant but if you are going through
all of this hassle what you are left
with in the end is a great starting
point which basically tells you where
you can create a lot of value with
relatively easy data operations
measures um so you got to prioritize and
choose accessible and highly valuable
projects to your organization and then
make sure you're not creating
lighthouses keep in mind it's never
about just creating a notebook which
will then be archived away once the
presentation is held try to create
infrastructure and this has been quite
abstract so
far so let's uh walk through two
projects we've been having
recently and we're going to start with
example one where we are we're
developing an AI application to improve
planning processes we were having a
customer
um and they were in the space of
planning large multi-year
projects and the problem is that
Staffing these long running projects is
relatively complex if a project runs for
more than a decade you got to hire
people you got to make sure you have the
right people for each project
phase and getting it wrong can delay
these projects and cost Millions so
there is a real need for to solve this
issue at the same time what they were
doing is every project planner took care
of each project individually and came up
with numbers controlling said sounds
about right probably or was asking
questions back but it was all based on
individual
experience so we set out to provide an
application uh providing a reliable
Baseline estimate so we didn't want to
automate this process but rather leave
enough space for planners to adjust it
up and down but take away the work of
doing it all from scratch every time and
just leave them with an up and down
adjustment in the
end so just remove the redundancies but
still allow for individual
expertise so we started working with the
customer and this approach has the key
advantages if you're going for a high
value application in the
beginning that you're creating immediate
value this can help you to get skeptical
actors on board because you're
immediately showing okay if we're
transitioning away from silos we're
actually creating something that will
benefit everyone in the organization not
only in the very long run but already in
the medium
term um also if you get started with a
specific application in mind instead of
just doing broad architectural thinking
you will run into issues that you didn't
see coming which is very valuable in its
own right because it tells you even more
about your organization's
data that's what I put down here on the
slide as the last point point it can
serve a cryst as a crystallization point
for future
improvements an
example we got started with our
application in this instance we achieved
good first results and we thought hey
just add more data let's improve this
let's make this really
great
however we soon ran into a couple of
data problems including an encrypted
file without exess key the only person
who ever knew that access key recently
retired which was a little bit
unfortunate so we had to figure out a
way around this we worked with an orphan
data warehouse so we could only take
data out of it but nobody knew how to
add data into
it and important data sources were not
integrated and especially stuff like the
Excel files you only really ever notice
if you start building an application
just from theoretical planning you will
not get
there talking about integration this
brings us to the second
example and this example highlights that
you need to tailor what you have what
you want to do in terms of data
operations specifically to your use
case in this case we had a customer with
strong data silos plenty of expertise in
each department everybody's super
competent just the communication between
the different department in terms of
data was severely
lacking and we tried to solve this
problem by implementing a data mesh to
keep the data in in the hands of the
local experts but at the same time
create reliable access throughout the
organization so we eliminate the need
for informal data
flows and if we replace informal data
flows we need formal data flows so we
set up a bunch of ETL pipelines to
automate the data movement from the data
within the department to the provided
API outwards
facing um we implemented some data
quality management measures like
automatic data validation and
contractually defined
standards and these helped us to create
trust between the different
departments so you don't have to check
every time you're in contact with your
other
department did they give us the right
thing does it have the right format no
you can just develop you know what you
get from the API and this alone already
alleviates a lot of
inefficiencies
we did all of this dockerized deployed
on Ms
Azure uh for the obvious reason we
wanted to have great scaling in the
future uh we deployed terraform to keep
the cloud configuration reproducibly
versioned just to make sure that we know
which um software version goes with
which infrastructure
version and doing all of this we were
still hyperscaler independent which is
really cool because we implemented it
all using open source software not
relying on proprietary Services by the
cloud uh vendor so if our customer ever
says let's move this from Azure to
Google I'm not saying it's not a lot of
work but it can be done which is really
cool I
think that's it from my
part in case you're having any questions
I'm here do we have time for questions
what's have time for
[Applause]
questions we have
question yes but this is only because
you should really think about who you L
your stuff so thanks Fabian for never
returning the thing here but I the the
professional thing here but we can still
improvise with this cooking stick to
microphone Alex you look threatening yes
I'm very sorry and thanks again Fabia
ban if you're watching
yeah uh yeah
questions no questions ah
question yeah first of all thanks a lot
for the for the talk very uh very nice
um I was just wondering about um sort of
the the data that gets sort of stuck in
Excel files I mean you hear it more
often and it's there because people like
Excel how could you convince them to
turn this or get the data out of it and
turn this into a data mhine ETL
pipelines and um all that that's the the
problem if you will it's not only about
creating infrastructure but you also
have to
change data
culture um you got to get people to
understand that having several copies of
a Excel files and working off of them
instead of using the API to draw the
data a new every time creates a lot of
problems and it just takes significant
amount of
convincing and just general upskilling
making people more data aware that's
part of the that's the non-technical
part of becoming a data driven
organization that's the culture aspect
if you will oh actually if I might add
to that we ask them hey can you please
look in all your papers or somebody
noted put down the password because the
people were really in retirement so yes
so that that's pretty convincing as well
like it's good to have have a bad
example at
hand yeah it's a bad practice so um yeah
more
questions
yes another a question thank you very
much for your talk I was wondering so
since there are so many Excel lists
going around and um which techniques do
you use to turn Excel files into
reliable
databases
um that depends on the Excel file to be
honest if it's something that has been
passed around multiple times already in
the organization is probably best just
work off of the single point of Truth
just get rid of
it
and the other
scenarios you just got to feed the Excel
file into your um into your database at
one
point I think that's the only reasonable
way to go edit to the overall pool of
data transition away from using Excel to
store important information generally so
it's basically just there are already
all of the libraries and it's just an
API call convert Excel to SQL
or how can I
Alex you want I may add to that we we
like to put the Excel files into pet and
work with pet files and eventually also
integrate pet files into a data Hub so
make them more accessible but that's
also just like an intermediary solution
because yeah we don't really want to
work on XX file or single file formats
except we say okay it's a big solution
historical data that's something
something else you and actually like
integrate it into um like a database
data hub or like an yeah an organized
and data managed
system so sorry for the slid question
uh yes
just you got you got an
image doesn't
here oh maybe I um that's unfortunate
that's unfortunate but okay in the
meantime maybe I can ask the so how do
you manage to be vendor independ and at
the same time to provide some
authentication and authorization system
for personalized users for
applications um
for Alex do you want to take this
question sorry I didn't get the question
I was uh a question sorry so how do you
manage to be vendor independent that you
don't use the services from Asher or UCP
and at the same time you implement
authentication and authorization in a
proper
way I mean we we use open source for
everything so of course you will never
it's not just like okay you cannot use
the same terraform of course to have
multi multiple hyperscalers so there's a
certain vendor I wouldn't call it login
but like inflexibility but you can fix
that because like program code
dockerized um we like to work with files
so um I think uh when the logging in the
cloud happens if you of course use their
databases use their extra services this
is where we Define window login so of
course like with author authentication
and other services so it's it's it's a
bit more of course moving from One Cloud
to the other is still work it's not just
like hey switch
unfortunately all right then hope the
next Works say next talk is Max but yeah
please give it yeah sorry for that
yeah
Max has a microphone and we will see
what happens to the blue screen
here now that we at such a smooth
transition in one way I hope that we can
reproduce that yes no I think
yes let me
check my my resolution is reacting to
something
yeah
so thank you very much yes
yeah so please welcome Max from applied
AI uh please stay here with the camera
like this here okay away and yeah welome
Max voice
talk oh it's dat oh okay that's
bad so that work for
for uh just let me try something because
sometimes it's just
like
sorry for the
break
yep
SP
yeah
in a
bar Banger the crowd crowd
[Applause]
I'm
yes HDMI is one of the best standards
ever you can
see
near